um
hello everyone uh in this session we
have five amazing papers each paper gets
12 minutes
and
so
a talk of 10 minutes and around 2
minutes for
questions and
the first paper is by
if you can share your slides that's
so should i start oh yes yep the first
question is about dynamic matching
algorithms under where it takes a plate
time and laser
let's go it presents this paper go ahead
from television university
uh thanks
hi everyone
i'm lazar
in this work i will talk about uh
dynamic matchings under vertex updates
and this is a joint work with hung shai
in virginia
we study graph matchings which is a
fundamental problem and it has been
extensively studied
in particular we'll be interested in
maximal matching
and also to in maximum cardinality
matching or mcm and in particular better
than two approximations than the better
into approximations
we study matchings in dynamic setting in
the standard dynamic setting where we
have edge updates there are many results
in contrast in the setting of vertex
updates
we have only incremental or decremental
setting and there is very
very few results
there are no results on fully dynamic
matchings on the vertex updates
except for one work which shows how to
maintain the size
of mcm
in by protect wraps with one side fixed
in this work we initiate the
systematic study of fully dynamic
matchings under vertex updates
in the standard dynamics setting
we have the notions of worst case update
time and the notion of amortized update
time
the state of the art for maximal
matching
is a deterministic square root of m
update time and randomized constant
update time and we note that there is no
deterministic subpolynomial of data
for better than two approximation to mcm
there are various uh different results
but we note that here also there is no
um
strictly better than two approximation
for uh which achieves sub polynomial
update time
we now switch
our focus to vertex updates
here we have notion of worst case update
time
which is maximum ti and also the
amortized update time which is total run
time divided by the overall number of
edits inserted or deleted from the graph
another
notion that we'll be interested in is
the recourse bound which is the total
number of changes which is the number of
changes to the outputs matching per
update step and it can be either worst
case or amortized
and there is a recent theorem which says
that uh any gamma mcm with an update
time t can be transformed as a black box
so another algorithm with a slightly
worse
approximation guarantee and update time
but now the
the bond on the recourse is worst case
one over epsilon
and this transformation applies both to
vertex and edge updates
i'll now summarize the previous work all
the previous results concern
either incremental
either incremental setting with vibrated
graphs when one side is fixed
or the decremental setting with also
bipartite graphs one side is fixed
except for one result that i previously
mentioned all the previous results
concern
either incremental or decremental
setting and in particular there is an
exact
mcm in m square root of n time
which achieves uh amortized recourse of
square root of n
there is also one plus epsilon
approximation
uh in n over epsilon time and amortiza
is requires one over epsilon
and there is also an exact mcm in uh
amortize with the amortized recourse of
log squared of n
we also note that we can get for the
second result
worst case bound on the recourse while
maintaining the other current is same
i'll now switch to our contribution
our work draws connection between
dynamic graph algorithms and online
algorithms
in dynamic graph algorithms we usually
consider edge updates and optimize the
update time
and the decisions can be revoked
in online algorithms we usually consider
vertex updates incremental graphs
and would like to optimize the
competitive ratio and the decisions here
are irrevocable almost always
the previous work on dynamic matchings
concerns either incremental or
decremental setting
and this paper is first to focus on
fully dynamic matchings on the vertex
updates
i'll now summarize our results the first
result concerns bipartite graphs where
one side is fixed and the other
dynamically changes
in this
setting we observe that there is a
simple maximal matching algorithm which
gives a constant amortized update time
in addition this algorithm never removes
an edge from the matching we call such
an algorithm an irrevocable algorithm
and note that
irrevocable algorithm for maximum
matching implies constant worst case
bound on the recourse
next we consider what we call medium
dynamic settings here we have vibrated
graph with the both sides dynamically
changing
and for this setting
we show that we show polynomial lower
bounds for update time for irrevocable
maximal matching
under some popular conjectures such as
omv and triangle detection
these lower bounds extend to medium to
the decremental setting assuming that we
can fix the initial matching
and in contrast to these polynomial
lower bounds on irrevocable maximal
matching which show that there is one
revocable maximal matching with a
constant update time meaning that this
algorithm removes at most one edge
per update step
in addition this algorithm works in even
more general setting which we call
general dynamic
thus we show uh this theorem so there is
a deterministic one revocable algorithm
with a constant update time and we note
that
bound of i on revocability implies uh
all of our of i bound on the recourse
this shows us that revocability is a
pivotal measure of maximal matching
algorithms on one hand we have
polynomial lower bounds for irrevocable
algorithms and on the other hand we have
a constant update time for
one revocable algorithm
we also note that deterministic state of
the art under edge updates is square
root of them whereas we have shown
constants update time under vertex
updates
finally back to the basic dynamic
setting
we show that one can maintain an e over
a minus one approximates mcm in a
constant update time
this algorithm builds
on the classic online algorithm of kdb
in particular we show how
kvv matching can be maintained in this
setting where the clients can both be
inserted and deleted from the graph in
constant
update time in addition we can get a
worst case bound
of one over epsilon of the recourse
while losing slightly
on the approximation guarantee and the
update time
in this work we initiate the study of
fully dynamic matchings on the vertex
updates
our main
focus is on maximal matching
first we show simple irrevocable
algorithm with a constant update time
in the basic dynamic setting second we
showed
amortized polynomial lower bounds for
update time of irrevocable algorithms
under some popular conjectures such as
coinv and triangle detection these lower
bounds apply to
bipartite graphs where both sides
dynamically change
finally we contrast these lower bounds
with the one revocable algorithm with a
constant
update time
which works in the general dynamic
setting
we identify revocability as a pivotal
measure of maximum matching algorithms
in
in addition
this is a more refined measure than the
record response
we also study better than two
approximations to mcm
we show how to maintain an e over e
minus one approximation to the mcm in a
constant update time in basic dynamic
setting and this algorithm builds
on the ranking algorithm of kvb
we note that uh getting even a
subpolynomial update time under edge
updates is a major open problem and it
will be interesting to see if one can
get
anything interesting for the setting
between the standard one of edge updates
and the basic dynamic setting
of vertex updates such as the medium
dynamic setting
in this work we showed how the insights
from the area of online algorithms can
be used to improve state of the art
of state of the art of dynamic graph
algorithms
we anticipate that tutorial study of
these two fields together rather than
independently would
contribute significantly to improving
the state of the arts of both of them
thank you
uh i don't hear you sorry
thank you for the amazing talk
are there any questions from the
audience
have a little time
okay and so in that case
maybe the next presenter should share
their sites
okay thanks
thank you
hello um my name is
yeah
my name is i would like to tell you
about the beating the poker algorithm
for dynamic matching this is the joint
work with uh i mean so very david white
from stanford university
uh in the dynamic matching problem we
are given a graph undergoing insertion
and edge deletions and the goal is to
maintain a large matching after each
update
so uh
we use new object to show the size of
the maximum matching in the graph
the hardest results in the literature
shows that we cannot maintain an exact
maximum matching uh
fast so instead we are looking for
approximate dynamic matching
and there are two key properties that
are important when uh when we are
talking about uh appropriate dynamic
matching algorithms the first one is
update time which is the time that we
spend after each insertion and deletions
to maintain our
matching and also
approximation factor which is the ratio
between the
matching that we are reporting and the
maximum matching of the current graph
dynamic matching has been studied
intensively intensely over the years
this is the list of the works that
about the dynamic matching problem
but before going to detail of our
algorithm and also talking about prior
works and let's look at the simple
knives algorithm that
that does not want you to publish
anywhere
um
so we call it the folklore algorithm in
the folklore algorithm
if an edge inserted to the graph and
both of its endpoints are free we add
the edge
to our matching
uh if an is deleted from the graph and
it's not
a matching edge we just we do nothing
and otherwise if for each of its end
point we will we scan all
all of its neighbors to find the
neighbor w that is not matched and then
we
match vmw together
so and the update time of this algorithm
is order of end because for each
endpoint we need to scan all this all of
its neighbors and it maintains a maximum
matching which is a two approximation
uh surprisingly this
algorithm
was unbeaten until this year which means
that there is no deterministic two minus
epsilon approximation algorithm with
small order of and worst case update
time all the prior works try to beat the
popular algorithm with some realization
like randomization or having amortized
update
time uh our main result is that there is
a deterministic slightly better than two
approximate uh dynamic matching
algorithm with worst case update time of
uh order of and three quarter
also there are two uh follow-up words
one by peter kiss in i uh i said 2020
exactly after this stack
and one by january at all in sosa 20 and
22.
and both of these works get better
approximation ratio and update them but
our
method is completely different
and there are several priority works
that
beat the folklore algorithm using some
structural assumption on the input graph
the first one is based on uh is for
bounded degree graphs that's uh that is
designed by gupta and pain in 2013
uh which they proved that there existed
a deterministic one plus epsilon
approximation in worst case update time
of order of delta which delta is the
maximum degree of the graph
and this algorithm has been used a lot
in as a subroutine to design other and
dynamic
matching algorithms this is the list of
the works that use this uh results
as their subroutine before our work and
also this is a list of words that use
this
algorithm as a subroutine after our work
and
in order to use this um
algorithm by good time thing we need to
maintain a bounded degree subgraph which
contains a large machine called
sparsifier so if we can maintain a
sparsifier fast then we can apply the
gupta pen results to get a large
matching in fast running time
also for bipartite graphs there's a
result by bernstein and stein in 2015
that they showed that there's they exist
the feministic three plus epsilon
approximation inverse case update time
of root n for bipartite graphs but
there's no
uh prior works that show how we can
solve the general dynamic matching
problem using this
bipartite graph algorithm this is our
contribution this is the contribution of
our work that we show how we can reduce
the general dynamic matching to
dynamic bipartite matching
uh our starting point is the spartifier
called camera by
introduced by the charlie henzinger
italiano in 2018
uh an epstein d kernel of graph g is a
subject k such that its maximum degree
is at most d and also for each edge that
is not appeared in the
kernel at least one of its end point has
a degree uh
greater than or equal to d times one
minus epsilon or roughly greater than
or at least roughly equal to d
and
so here in this example this kdd which
is complete bipartite
graph which denotes
on each side is a journal and all the
black which is that doesn't that are not
in the
kernel has one
endpoint with degree equal to d
and the kernel number suggests that the
the
if k is an epsilon d kernel of graph g
then the size of the maximum matching of
g is less than or equal to plus the
depth of time maximum matching of k so
it's a two plus epsilon sparsifier
uh
in order to use the
channels i mean as a reminder we know
how to
uh
how to find the maximum matching of a
bounded degree subgraph in the in
worst case update time of order of delta
so in order to get two plus epsilon
approximation we can come by combine
kernel with
this algorithm
uh if t is the channel maintenance
update time and cb the number of the
changes to the kernel per updates and db
the kernel degree then we'll have the
order of t plus c times the algorithm
for uh for
two plus epsilon approximation uh but
the bad news is that all the
prior the term second algorithm has uh c
times d equal to omega and
uh this c times d uh appear in the
update because after each update to the
kernel we need to apply the good damping
results on top of that
to update them actually
our second result is that the existing
term lists each on the kernel algorithm
and worst case update time of order of
and we'll give it only one change to the
kind of per update
uh
now we have a two plus epsilon
approximation sub linear time now we are
uh going to break the barrier of two so
if kernel k uh contains the large
matching or it's better in other words
it's better than two approximation then
we are done
otherwise we show that kernel tray
contains nearly maximal matching m which
means that
which means that if we remove a few
vertices from the graph then
the current matching is the maximum
matching
um
also if that augmenting pass be an
alternating pass that starts from an
ends on three vertices um
that alternate between non matching and
matching edges
if you have augmenting paths we can fill
up the edges to get a larger matching
we show that
this
nearly maximal matching and that is not
better than two approximation contain
many short augmenting passes
and the general idea is that um
when when we are in the tie case of the
kernel we show that
it contains many length stereo
augmenting passes with respect to
matching up with respect to m and
the augmenting passes to get better than
two approximation and the question is
how we can find these missing edges from
the
kernel
the answer is that most of these missing
edges are between a low d low degree and
high degree nodes in the kernel so if we
can maintain a bipartite matching
between a low and high degree nodes
internal then we can then we can beat
the
barrier of two
so here's our main result that exists
the deterministic is slightly better
than two approximate dynamic matching
algorithm with worst case update time of
order into three quarter
and there are several interesting open
questions the first one is that what's
the best approximation in small order of
n currently three half plus epsilon but
by the work of granted bernie sanders
time
uh also uh
uh are also by the follow-up words by
case and altogether
uh and the the second question is that
can we get a two minus some constant
approximation in poly logarithmic update
time
and what is the fastest one plus epsilon
approximation currently is root n by
work of group domain thank you
thank you mohammed for amazing talk
let's see if there any questions from
the audience
we have four minutes before we start the
next stack
so
do you think that your approach could be
used to
get something which is a bit slower than
root n but achieves a bit better than
two-thirds approximation
currently yeah we
talked about this uh
question but currently our operation
doesn't work but because
there's some hidden parts in our
approach that we that's a low degree
node and high degree nodes can swap very
quickly and so we instead use the approx
approximate degree to handle this
problem and this causes a high running
time
and currently i don't know if it's
possible to
solve this problem or not but maybe in
the future yeah
thank you
any other questions
you
uh peter you may want to start sharing
your slides but you should stay you
should wait for two minutes before you
start the time
one minute
so where should i start
just wait a little
okay
sure
so our next talk is by peter kiss about
the deterministic dynamic matching in
worst case of daytime
you cannot start now
thank you
so yeah i'm a phd student at the
university of work
and
i would like to say special thanks to my
supervisor shyam bhattacharya and touch
upon serenbrook
for their help with this publication
so
the problem setting is similar to the
previous presentation that we are
working on the matching problem in
simple graphs where we're looking for
a large set of vertex disjoint edges
and we will say that the matching m is
alpha approximate if it has size one
over alpha times the maximum matching
size the mu of g will refer to the
maximum matching size and we will be
working in the dynamic setting the fully
dynamic setting in particular
that is our goal is to maintain this
matching under edge insertions and
deletions
and we want to be way faster than just
recomputing the matching after each
update step
and as highlighted by previous talks
there's a difference between worst case
update time and amortized update time as
worst case of this time is kind of like
the intuitive way of thinking about
update time that how much how many steps
the algorithm takes per update well a
more test update time is the average
update time over a series of steps worst
case update time is superior obviously
you know by definition and the goal of
this paper is to
improve uh
our dynamic algorithm update times from
amortized worst case in a somewhat black
box manner
so this is a dynamic matching problem in
particular is a very vast study problem
these are just some of the more
recent state-of-the-art results just in
the fully dynamic setting
and we are bringing
in some new approximation ratio and
running time tradeoffs into the worst
case realm with this paper in particular
in particular for two plus epsilon
approximation which we will do in
polylog and three over two plus epsilon
which we can achieve in root n
oh had through 10 so there's a little of
uh anti-little of one factor involved
there and i would like to mention that
parallel to our work uh slightly faster
running time for three over two plus
epsilon was uh
found by gardening at all
uh right
okay so
our goal is to dynamize amortize rebuild
based algorithms and i for that i would
have to explain what how much says
rebuild based algorithm is and quite a
lot of dynamic algorithms work like this
they essentially
exploit the robustness of the data
structure they're maintaining and if
you're thinking about matching this
works is the following way if i
calculate the matching which i can do in
semi-linear time using my favorite
matching algorithm that's going to stay
a one plus epsilon approximate matching
for a few updates
and
after these few updates have happened i
can just recalculate this matching and
amortize the cost of this rebuild over
the previous updates this is a very sort
of standard trick to use
and
you can achieve non-trivial bounds with
this
method
now obviously this previous like what
has rebuilds based methods are
inherently uh run with america's update
times yes
in the paper we will be using a slightly
stronger property or running time
property than amortized which was
introduced by nalankai so
for a slightly different problem which
we call k batch dynamic
which is very similar to amortized but
if an algorithm is cape edge dynamic the
algorithm itself can
identify where it will split the input
sequence the input sequence of updates
into like k subsequences and it can
guarantee that the amortization sort of
happens over those subsequences so to
wait to imagine that if this is my
subsequence then i can split it into
five ways as i want to
and
the average running time is going to
the every the running time is going to
be average within these
subsequences essentially the goal the
point here is that there's not going to
be a small subsequence where i spend a
lot of time
uh
doing something
like if a subsequence here which i
choose a batch which i choose to be
small then the update time over that
batch is going to be small so this is a
slightly stronger property than just
normal amortization because i can select
where the amortization sort of happens
right so this is not
our work we're just using this
and
touch
i'm using the wrong names apologies for
that uh so not honking cerak has shown
um
implicitly they didn't explicitly state
this but essentially you can formulate
their work
as the following if you have a batch
dynamic algorithm with something like
log n batches
then you can turn it into like this
complicated algorithm which has several
output tapes
um
like about log n output tapes
and it runs in worst case update time
and guarantees that one of those output
tapes at all times the output is correct
and in the matching problem this is
quite convenient for us because the
union of a small number of matchings is
just a graph with small maximum degree
and on such graphs there's a
result quoted by the previous
presenter as well from grifton bank
which we can we can efficiently solve
the dynamic matching problem for the
dynamic setting so
essentially
as soon as we
uh
just reduced it to log n output tapes or
or till the one output tapes we are done
so our goal really here is
to find an amortized rebuild based
algorithm improve it to batch dynamic
uh improve it to worst case update time
on several batches and then just solve
the problem on that like this four-step
process and improving an amortized
rebuild based algorithm to capac dynamic
is actually surprisingly easy
and this this kind of methods don't are
not restricted to matching in particular
what you can do is that you start off
similarly as with your normal amortized
rebuild algorithm but you rebuild a bit
more often
and you when you start a new batch you
make sure that you don't rebuild until a
certain while
so you don't run into a situation where
you made a rebuild during a very short
batch and even though that bet is kind
of short you're spending a lot of time
during the when that batch happens
it's essentially simple as that
on a high level
and yeah so this can this method leads
to the following four-step process
you design an amortized rebuild based
algorithm you improve it to batch
dynamic through just
choosing your rebuilds more carefully
you improve it to
worst case update time on several output
tapes
using the
algorithm for non-on ksr underrank and
then you solve the problem on the union
of these days if your problem happens to
be one which is easier to be solved on
the union of these tapes and matching
happens to be such a problem
okay
um so we
have two results in this particular
paper
one of them is duplication approximation
in polylog update time and this one was
easier to derive using this framework
because the previous work
me and my supervisor
was essentially amortized rebuild based
so
as you just apply the framework straight
away you get the result what you're
looking for what was a bit more subtle
is to
achieve theory two perception
approximation in a bad route and update
time because there were just components
missing to getting
there there was no amortized rebuild
based algorithm for three over two plus
epsilon
approximation yet
but as soon as that is generated the
rest of the paper is applied in like a
black box manner
um
so every amorite has rebuilt base
algorithm is really reliant on a robust
data structure
for example a matching itself just
because it contains like a low number of
edges is not very robust
because
if you just apply straightforward
amortized rebuilds you get something of
order m over the size of the matching
it's not very fast
so we you needed a robust data structure
for every kind of matching every kind of
amortization based algorithm our choice
was an edcs
which is which was introduced by a very
influential paper of bernstein stein
from 2015
on icalp i think
um
and
it is already a fairly robust data
structure if the parameters of it are
selected well there's lots of details on
it here this is on a very high level but
you can make it robust against mu of g
times root of one updates
where mu of g as i mentioned stands for
the maximum matching size so this is
sufficient for our purpose given we can
construct it quickly and given the
matching size is relatively large within
the graph and
we do need to find these two steps to
make it work on the other hand
i do note that as
with the previous presenter also said
that
we are just maintaining a data structure
within the graph which is guaranteed to
contain a large matching and within that
subgraph that data structure there's a
very influential algorithm my group
template which just maintains our
matching right away in a black box
manner this is very common when it comes
to fully dynamic matching algorithms
so the two difficulties with this is
that there was no semi-linear algorithm
for finding an edcs
and it is not guaranteed that the
matching size is large the matching size
could be of a scale of root n
and then we get worse update times
so
we show a semilinear algorithm for
finding an edcs sort of
i'm not sure if an edcs can actually be
found in semi-linear time
on a high level
algorithms which find an actual edcs
construct a net set edge by edge and
they need to insert or remove an edge
about
or order m times but the issue is that
these edges also need to be found
somehow and this is why it just ends up
being slower than linear the number of
edges instead we came up with something
which is like a streaming algorithm
which doesn't exactly compute an edc as
it computes any dcs which is locally
damaged in some
parts of the graph it might not be
perfect but but assuming that the
matching size is large we can kind of
omit
a small part of the graph from our
calculations
so
it essentially is going to fulfill our
purpose assuming we can guarantee the
other property
um
and
there were already there was already a
method uh by assadian oh i think i've
missed that all there apologies uh from
2019
in a slightly different context for
guaranteeing this property am i running
out of time uh yeah
i'm sorry anyway so this is the end of
it and we improved that
with some extra polylog or a little
anti-low of one factors to randomize
against adaptive and deterministic okay
uh
yeah
right thank you for your very
interesting tag we have
a little time for questions
i thought it is
oh don't worry
not a question
okay so
thank you peter
the next presenter
please share your strides
my slides visible
yes so the next stock is by edward pine
and it's about local access to random
works
hi everyone uh i'm going to be
presenting local access to random walks
and this is joint work with amartya
shankar biswas and ronnie grubenfeld
so the algorithmic problem we're
considering in this paper is a really
fundamental one one of my favorites and
it's the idea of taking a random block
so
if we start at some fixed vertex in a
graph and we want to take a random walk
of length t we can do it by essentially
t units of computation just by add our
card vertex generate a new neighbor and
go to that name
but what if we only want the position of
this walk at certain times so we're
running some algorithm that relies on
this random lock but in reality we want
to know things like
where's the walk at time 300 maybe it's
at v300
where's the walk at time ten thousands
is it v ten thousand
position of time twenty seven uh and so
on and so forth
and so
the important thing about the answers
we'd like here is that maybe there's a
way to get just the information we need
the position of the walk at these four
time steps without actually taking a
walk of length 10 000 which could be a
much more computationally expensive
but at the same time we do want it to be
the case that the position of this walk
at those positions corresponds to a real
random walk they need to be consistent
so maybe let's say that these four
positions are coming from
the squiggle on the graph that can
represent the actual random walk but all
we want to know is the position at some
sparse
subset of those coordinates
and so this is a is a
comes in line with some recent works on
local computation algorithms for big
random objects so um this
line of work was introduced by evan levy
medina and rosen and biswas rubinfeld
and yopiani
and the type of algorithm we're looking
for
we can call a local access algorithm
and this is some algorithm a that
essentially acts as an oracle that
allows query access to some object w
drawn from some distribution over
objects d so in this case our
distribution over objects is random
walks on a graph
and we want to draw an object from that
distribution a random walk and then
answer queries about it so where's the
walk at time t naught t one etcetera
etcetera
and these algorithms are given access to
a read-only shared random string which
will always denote r
and between each query this algorithm
has its memory erased so it's not able
to remember previous things that it's
returned about the walk it's only
allowed to keep its random string
and so another uh way of thinking about
this where we um
a weaker notion where we don't require
the algorithm of memory to be erased is
we have some algorithm a sitting between
a graph g and a user who wants to make
queries and we get some query give us
the position of the lock at time t
naught
and we make some probes to the graph
maybe use our random string to help us
make those probes and then we return a
vertex the walk is at position v naught
at time t naught
and we get another query maybe we can
answer that without making any
additional probes
we get another query and so on and so
forth
so this is our model uh and the first
set of our results we get are based on
the expansion of the graph which is a
natural parameter to think about when
working with random walks
first we show that given neighbor probe
access to a deregular undirected graph g
with spectral expansion lambda there's a
local access algorithm for walks on g
with per query work roughly 1 over 1
minus lambda times root n
so on an expander with constant spectral
gap this is roughly root n work per
at the same time we show that any
algorithm that provides local access to
walks on random deregular graphs
requires roughly root and work per
clarity and because random deregular
graphs are expanders with good
probability this is in some sense a
nearly matching lower bound
we won't have time to get into the
details of either the upper bound or the
lower bound construction but i'll try
and at least present the algorithm for
the upper bound because it's quite
simple
our idea is to divide the walk into
blocks and then only solve for the
position of the walk in each block when
we get a query
what we're going to do is we're going to
take k to be some constant times the
mixing time of the graph which depends
on the expansion times log n
um and for each integer multiple of k
we'll let the position of the walk at
that multiple be just a uniformly random
vertex so generate a number through one
through n using our random tape
set v naught in this way vk v2k etc
but then the question is
one of the queries we might need to
answer is what's the position of the
walk between these two queries between
these two times
so in order to do that we need to
determine the position of this walk
between these break points
so just zooming in on that example
suppose we get some query t that lies
between i times k and i plus 1 times k
and suppose we've already determined uh
the position of the walk at the these
boundary times which is easy because we
can generate this number through one
through n
what we're then going to do is we're
going to start at one of these endpoints
and take a walk of length k over two
and we're going to go to the other end
point and likewise take a walk of k over
two
and we're going to continue this
procedure
and so on and so forth until eventually
we're going to get a collision we're
going to get walks from both of these
endpoints that after k for two steps lie
in the same place
and all we're going to do is we're going
to say that this first colliding pair
determines the walk between time ik and
i plus 1k
and the nice feature of this of this
algorithm first it's simple to analyze
and second it's very clear that if
instead we'd gotten a query at time t
plus one
we would have determined the walk in the
exact same way so we would have
generated the same endpoints because we
were just using the same place in the
random tape
and we would have found the same first
collision and so our procedure is
consistent and it does not need to
remember the previous queries that we've
got
so that's the upper bound the lower
bound is is more involved but i'll try
and give one lemma and some high level
intuition for howard functions
uh so again the lower bound says that
any algorithm that provides local access
to walks on random deregular graphs
requires roughly root end work program
and the main structural lemma that
allows us to understand how these
algorithms um how much these algorithms
are learning about random deregular
graphs states that given probe access to
a random graph drawn from the
distribution of random irregular graphs
any possibly adaptive sequence of less
than root n neighbor probes will fail to
find a cycle in this graph with
probability 0.99
and the hidden constants here depend on
the degree
and the proof of this uses the
configuration model for degree sequences
and we won't detail it
the idea for this lower bound therefore
is that the algorithm does not know
enough about the graph to give
convincing answers
what we're going to do when we're faced
with this algorithm that we want to show
cannot do a good job is we ask it for
the position of the walk at time t
naught times 0
and time root n
and the algorithm then has to commit and
return two vertices v naught and v root
n
but the algorithm was only allowed
significantly less than root n probes to
answer those first two queries
and so it either doesn't know a path
from v naught to v root n so it uh it
knows no sequence of connecting edges in
the graph
or it knows a path but the path is much
shorter than root n
so these two vertices have distance
which is less than their claim time
difference by by some big factor
and in either case we give further
sequences of queries to the algorithm
that force the algorithm to reveal some
inconsistency some aspect of the walk
that occurs with vanishing probability
in a truly random walk
so these are results in terms of of the
expansion of the graph but we give some
other results which are much better when
we have additional algebraic structure
in particular if we have a g on a
billion calorie graph of degree d
there's a local access algorithm with
time for query poly d log n so if we
have a constant degree of the alien
kelly graph we get poly log n time per
query
and this does give us efficient local
access to some of our favorite graphs
like the cycle the hypercube and
families of login degree expanders
finally i'll end with some open problems
and perhaps the most natural one is
local access to more random objects and
in particular one interesting question
is can we get local access to random
deregular graphs themselves
so is there some algorithm that allows
us query access to say what's the
neighbor of this vertex
and we generate these neighbors in a
fast way and second uh related to the
prior work several of these fireworks
gave local access algorithms that
did not forget their previous queries so
they gave access to things like random
catalan objects and gnp graphs
but they did not have the property that
they were memoryless and so it'd be
interesting to see if these results can
be converted to the memoryless setting
so thank you and i can take questions
thank you for your very amazing talk
now let's see if you have any questions
from the audience
if there are no questions we have to
wait
around two minutes to start the next
stop i see a q a question
oh okay
let's see
uh someone has a question um
can we let them ask the question
i don't know
can you unmute yourself and ask the
question or you just want to type that
works also
hi
so my question is
are you using the property of random
walks that there's sort of
less freedom towards the beginning of
the walk and then that increases over
the course of the walk or is the
algorithm sort of
not relying on that property
uh our upper bounds the the feature of
random walks that our upper bounds rely
on at least the the spectral based upper
bound is that after more than the mixing
time number of steps conditioning on
some vertices at the start of the walk
does very little to change the
probability of being at a vertex after
that number of steps so yes we we are
using something like that property
and then this collision based uh this
finding collisions approach is basically
we have two positions that are far away
from each other that we can basically
just determine independently how do we
stitch those together into something
that looks plausible because as we get
closer to those endpoints making up
vertices independently would would sort
of obviously not work
okay that makes sense
okay so it's it's it's this like
differing degrees of independence at
differing distances in the walk is
what's crucial all right thank you
are there any other
questions
okay thank you
so
the next presenter
please share yourself
[Music]
do we have anyone from the test paper
uniform brackets containers and
combinatorial macbook regions
um
um
mark is there a way to contact them
did you reach out to them when was the
last time you heard from them
uh i just sent them an email a couple of
days ago
hold on so i might be getting
wait uh
i don't see anything from them
let's see
i just emailed them by one of the
authors
but
i don't think that they are likely to
respond soon
it may have been a time zone
no it could be i mean we are also we
have a mission video so
[Music]
but let's wait maybe
a few more minutes
in just in case
yeah we can wait a couple of minutes and
i mean the good thing it's the last talk
at least so uh worst case we switch to
room b but
let's wait
[Music]
um so uh there is some response uh let's
let's wait uh one minute okay
okay
you
so i think one of the courses is
connecting now
i send him the link
do we see him
yes i
i just got connected
hi i'm very sorry for the
yeah i don't know what happened
kunal was supposed to give the talk and
he's not here
um
how much time do i have
um
like
six minutes
six minutes
um let me look i might have
because i didn't prepare any
presentation of course and here we
just had a new
baby a month ago and i'm here with her
basically
thank you
and okay but let's see what we can do in
six minutes
that's
that's the first time for me
um
i'm just looking for some slide
related slides that i have
okay so i'll share my screen
okay
okay let me tell you a few words about
you have five minutes now go ahead okay
okay so can you see my screen
yes
okay so
really in uh in five minutes
so really what this
paper is about is a we give a
method for a
proving uniform laws of large numbers so
i guess
you all know what the laws of large
numbers are
so um
so laws of numbers right this refers to
the property that if we have random
variable and we
sample independent uh
points from it and we take the empirical
average and the empirical average will
converge to the expectation
um
what are uniform laws of large numbers
so
assume we have a collection of random
variables so here we have a collection
of events f is a collection of events
a uniform law of large numbers
tells us that
this property this convergence of the
empirical frequency to the expectation
happens simultaneously
for all events in the family
right so um
so with probability at least one minus
delta
simultaneously all events in the family
satisfy that their empirical
measure
as observed on the on the on the samples
is close to the true measure
but most epsilon
so
which families which families of events
satisfy a uniform laws of large numbers
so
of course if we have any finite family
of events we can apply union bound
and get union and channel bound get
give us this this
bound the number of samples we need in
order to
have this epsilon delta approximation
and
but it's interesting to also ask when
when um which infinite families
satisfy
uniform laws of large numbers
and
and of course we cannot take a union
bound if we have an infinite family
but and and the the
and
basically what we
focused on in this paper is to develop
a way to finance
an infinite collection of uh
of events
in a way that will allow us to do that
and the idea is to consider the notion
of a bracket
okay so this is a very simple definition
so
let's assume we have some distribution
over the domain and we have some some
event
what is the bracket of this event an
epsilon bracket so these are just two
subsets one is contained in the event
and one contains the event
such that their measure is at most
epsilon the measure of the difference is
at most epsilon
and a brackets family so
given a family of interest f family of
events a bracket family g is is
any family offsets
such that for every f in f
there is an epsilon bracket in
calligraphic g
and
the
the simple observation is that if we can
find a finite family of events
g
which is a bracket family for f even if
f is infinite
then just give it one more minute
then
i'm sorry we have to stop the next
session starts right now
okay
um
okay that was yeah so again i'm sorry
for the
for the
yeah yeah
don't worry thank you everyone for your
amazing thanks and thank you for
participating
okay bye-bye i'll go back to my family
okay
oops
you